e sì perché proprio un periodo in cui ho
voglia di cambiare di rivoluzionario e
infatti stavo pensando no volevo un tuo
parere a riguardo ma se mi facessi tipo
la francia
adoro è da una vita che ti dico di fare
la frangia no vabbè ma farla subito
immediatamente amo stai scherzando spero
la francia una condanna a vita ma sei
impazzita
io l'ho fatta a nove anni fa quando vi
sono ricresciuto i capelli a 15 no
assolutamente bocciata non ti parlo più
è marie massa che ti sta proprio bene
questa frangia ma non pensavo proprio lo
sguardo poi ti da un aria più fresca più
giovanile più sbarazzina brava hai fatto
bene a farla a me proprio non piace
questa frangia io te l'avevo detto hai
fatto una cavolata cioè chi copre
proprio lo sguardo ma poi ti invecchia
dai cosa francia hai preso 20 anni cioè
ora è molto meglio senza da ho detto io
tutti dicevano che avere la francia era
scomodo e comodissimo passato il fondo
un attimo guarda qui perfetta e non si
stira
sembra sempre sporca cavolo non è
infatti mi piace un sacco addirittura ti
giuro stavo pensando di accorciarla
ancora un po sì un po più radical chic
un po più estrema vero rimedi per far
crescere in fretta i capelli soluzioni
per far crescere la frangia fai da te
economiche e poi il bello della francia
che basta una forcina e voilà la francia
sparisse perfetta e se mi stufo della
frangia basta una semplice forcina e il
gioco è fatto
la frangia è sparita dovrebbe
teoricamente a sparire non sparisse
quindi quando sarete in disaccordo lo
vedete parlarne poi dovrete votare la
soluzione tu potrai trovare qualcun
altro più tardi e alla fine tutti gli
snobbati saranno in parità ed è così che
funziona l'america non partì la francia
che ti vengono i brufoli fino a prova
contraria non ho mai avuto la pelle così
perfetta sono dicerie vedrai quanti
brufoli ti vengono con la francia io
l'ho fatta ieri e guarda cosa cosa
diavolo è successo la mia fronte vedi
non bisogna ascoltarle le persone se ti
fai da frange lo dovrei lavare ogni tre
minuti perché si sporcherà sempre da due
giorni crollavo e sono perfetti guarda
lavate i capelli ieri sera come è
possibile che la francia sia lercia
sporca schifosa a fare qualcosa
la la tavola frange basta c'è grossa ma
non hai capito quanto sto toccando da
quando mi sono fatto la francia c'è sono
proprio rock and roll mi sento più
stilosa più sicura di me stessa ma
guarda ma se tornassi indietro lo
rifarei mille altre modulo con la svolta
hai ragione
dovevo ascoltarti non mi crescerà mai
non la voglio dire mi fa schifo questa
faglia maledetto lo strappo
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video come
potete notare non mi sono fatta la
francia è una frangia finta poi devi
sapere con un commentino qui sotto se
avete la
francia oppure se non ce l'avete o se
gli piacerebbe farla se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al mio canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti
i nuovi video e come sempre ricordatevi
di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
instagram facebook e tic toc
io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao
[Musica]